so this is Alex's crazy content creation
model trademark pending hey here's what
I did
versus here's what you should do
feel the difference
this is what I did if it works for you
awesome if it doesn't work for you
notice what
here's 20 of my clients this is the
stuff that I'm doing with them right now
Rosie was struggling with some skin
condition we started giving her magic
pills and look at her skin now it's
amazing right but like this is what it
might not work for you but this will
work for her this will work for him this
will work for my clients right not what
you should do as soon as you point out
people hate you
because it sounds like you're preaching
it sounds like you have an ego and I
just don't think people like that
and so I think it's also switching from
how I
sort of other way switching from how to
how I so how to build a massive social
media following to how I built the
following that I have
feel difference
it's really small but really big in
terms of how people interpret your
message because it's like
I appreciate it
I think that what happens is when you
say it that way you're like you're
you're pulling back and saying like hey
like I hope this serves you in some way
like this is like me opening the kimono
this is stuff that's working right now
for me whereas the other way you're at
the pulpit commanding giving demand you
know demands and and commanding people
and I just don't think people like that
I mean how many people their entire
Instagram famous people shaking their
finger at you right it sucks I hate it
right and so I think it's really
speaking on your truths rather than
claiming to know the truth if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to
tube1kchallenge.com to join our next
live YouTube challenge you'll learn our
best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it